[Music]
Shark Bay off Australia's western coast
is home to an amazing diversity of life
including sea snakes sharks and of
course
sea turtles even though they are both
sea turtles the bays greens and
loggerheads are about as similar as
sleek fighter jets and lumbering tanks
despite their hard shells both are on
the menu for the bays top predator the
tiger shark but researchers here want to
know why loggerheads are killed five
times as often as their green cousins is
it just because the loggerheads are
slower to answer that
there's Crittercam a technology
developed by biologists and engineers at
the National Geographic Society
when the green turn away here turn right
hard right hard right ready
the green smooth shale is perfect for
the Crittercam suction once on it won't
come off until a magnesium washer
dissolves and releases the Crittercam
right here turn around for the
loggerheads rough shale the team uses a
harmless epoxy and a base plate which
will slough off after a few days
the other participant in this equation
the tiger shark is perfectly suited for
hunting large prey
the adults can grow to almost 15 feet
and 2,000 pounds they stalk from below
and rely on surprise the Tigers heavy
jaws are filled with serrated teeth that
can easily cut through turtle shell as
the Sharks thrash their bodies from side
to side but why are loggerheads their
primary victims at sundown the camera
from one of the loggerheads is released
and is ready for pickup
the first clue the loggerhead angles
towards the surface for air straight to
the danger zone and stays there for more
than two minutes plenty of time for a
tiger shark to take advantage the first
green turn true - it's faster nature
gives the Crittercam crew the runaround
before they can retrieve the camera
the footage reveals a startling contrast
the Green spends almost no time at the
surface one breath and then plunges back
to the safety of the sea bottom the
scientists find this pattern repeatedly
the critter cams have given them a
window into how speed agility and
behavior have helped the green turtles
to stay clear of tiger sharks and why so
many loggerheads bear the visible
consequences of being a slowpoke in
Australia's Shark Bay